[موسيقى]
الى باكستان حيث كثافه قاده احزاب تحالف
الحاكم هناك اتصالاتهم لاختيار قائد جديد
للجيش خلفا للجنرال قمر باجواء الذي
يتقاعد نهايه الشهر الحالي وبحسب وسائل
الاعلام المحليه فان من المتوقعين الاعلان
عن قائد الجيش الجديد خلال الايام القليله
القادمه ومن جهه اخرى يواصل مؤيده وحزب
انصاف بزعمت رئيس الحكومه السابقه عمران
خان مسيرتهم والاحتجاجيه نحو العاصمه
اصابات للمطالبه بتجديد موعد انتخابات
العامه
الحكومه الاحتلافيه بمحاوله تعيين جنرال
الموالي لاحزابها في منصب قائد الجيش
من اصابات ينضموا الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
عبد الرحمن مطر عبد الرحمن بدايه يعني
موضوع هذا الحوار الان بين قالت احزاب
التحالف او اتصالات الجريمه قالت احزاب
التحالف في باكستاني اختيار قائد جديد
لجيش يدعون
بدايه عن نهايه
السلطه وهامش ايضا القرار الذي يحظى به
هؤلاء القائد الاختيار قائد الجيش ومن
فعلا يختاروا من الجيش يختاروا الساسه من
يختارون الجيش قائد الجيش
سؤال مركبه معقد حقيقه عبد الصمد لكن بحسب
مواد الدستور فانه يحق فقط لرئيس الحكومه
اختيار قائد الجيش بناء على ترشيح من ااا
من القائد الحالي او من المؤسسه العسكريه
بشكل عام وبالفعل بحسب مقال وزير الدفاع
وايضا بحسب ما قال وزير الداخليه فان
المشاورات التي تجري حاليا ستتمخض عن
اختيار قائد جديد للجيش خلال اليومين
المقبلين على حد تعبير وزير الدفاع الذي
قال بانه بان الجيش يقدم همم اربعه اسماء
ترشح مرشح لرئيس الحكومه الذي يتعين عليه
اختيار واحد من هذه الاسماء الاربعه للشغل
المنصب التنفيذي والعسكري الارفع حقيقه
هنا في الباكستان ولا يخفى على احد عبد
الصمد ان باكستان التي حكمها العسكر خلال
تقريبا نصف عمرها المنتدى على مدار 75
عاما
فان للجيش بالتاكيد الكثير من النفوذ على
الساحه السياسيه هنا في باكستان بالرغم من
انه حاليا الحكم الحكومه المدنيه او
لاحزاب مدنيه الكثير من القاده السياسيين
هنا في باكستان وقاده الاحزاب عاده ما
يسعون لتعيين قائد الجيش يكونوا وليا لهم
او مقربا منهم ان صح التعبير في محاوله
ربما لاستماله المؤسسه العسكريه بشكل عام
هناك حاليا الكثير من همم الاستقطاب فيما
يتعلق باختيار قائد الجيش همم التحالف
الحاكم يجري المشاورات عمران خان بصفته
رئيس الحكومه السابق وقائد المعارضه انصح
التعبير في المرحله الحاليه يتحدث بشكل
يومي عن انه لا يحق لهؤلاء اختيار قائد
الجيش وانه لابد ان يتم اختيار القائد
الجيش بناء على التردديه والاقدميه ضمن
القوات المسلحه
لكن بالتاكيد
عبد الرحمن عذرا المقاطع بالنسبه لحدث
الثاني الذي نتابعه لباكستان الان عن كتاب
وهو هذه المسيره احتجاجيه وصلها انصار حزب
انصاف اين وصلت المسيره
المسيره ما اعتزال متواصله يتم تنظيم ما
يشبه التجمهر الشعبي في مدن البنجاب
الرابطه بين عاصمه اقليم البنجاب مدينه
لاهور والعاصمه الفدراليه لباكستان هنا
مدينه اسلام اباد على امتداد هذا الطريق
هناك الكثير من المدن والبلدات في كل يوم
هناك تجمهر لاتباع حزب انصاب زعامه عمران
خان في حدا هذه البلدات حتى على اعتبار
انه من المفترض ان يصل الى الاسلام بعد
خلال الايام القليله المقبله للمطالبه همم
بتحديد موعد الانتخابات عامه مبكرا لكن لا
يخفى حتى على احد ان ان حزب الانصاف ضمن
هذه المساله وضمن هذه المسيره ايضا يتحدث
عن اختيار قائد الجيش همم على اعتبار بانه
يريد ان يكون له كلمه ايضا في هذا الموضوع
لكن بالتاكيد المهد الهدف الاساسي من هذه
المسيره هو همم اجبار الحكومه على تحديد
موعد لانتخابات عامه مبكرا وليس انتظار
الموعد الرسمي في اغسطس من العام المقبل
عبد الصمد اشكرك
المطر مدير مكتب الجزيره في شكرا